okay let's go
let's go here it is and guess what we
are live
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
to your favorite podcast
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up y'all welcome back to riffing
with Griffin sometimes comedy sometimes
serious but 100 mean podcast Griffin
today I'm finally delving into it it's
time to talk about you Kanye West I
don't know what's going on with this
dude
Ticketmaster controversy with Taylor
Swift tickets a dude fell off a Carnival
Cruise Ship what would you do
and
Electric solar cars
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
remember
I don't know it just felt funkier today
I don't even know why
just felt funky welcome back to riffing
with Griffin
check me out
ericgirlfriend.com
for tour dates and
whatever information my little crazy
little podcast thanks for coming out
y'all uh make sure you subscribe share
hit the likes uh all that stuff help me
push the show with the different
algorithms you can support me on many
different ways you can support me on
Twitch Instagram you could be a YouTube
member uh you know I'm on Twitch
everything you could be a twitch
subscriber and you can also be a patreon
member which I I know I talk I say this
every single week but what I'm gonna
start doing next week because then I'm
gonna carry over into 2023 is we're
going to do a weekly
patreon only episode of like you know
weekly affirmations thoughts of the week
uh you know points of emphasis of things
so you know just random thoughts and
ideas you know uh just for me and my
small fan base that I love so much okay
so check that out and today everybody
this
um
this episode is brought to you by
doordash
doordash for a limited time our
listeners can also enjoy a gift for
themselves with 50 off up to twenty
dollar value and zero delivery fees when
you download the doordash app and enter
code refin
ish
all right welcome to riffing with
Griffin y'all I gotta poll up cause
that's what we're going to be talking
I'm gonna be talking about a little bit
today so today's poll that's up right
now you want to check it out if you're
just listening right now for the first
time you're listening on on whatever
podcast platform you're listening to
thanks for coming back to the show I
appreciate you guys for the ones that
listen you're in your car you're at work
or you're working out whatever it is
you're doing you just like listening to
my crazy voice while you're doing that
stuff I appreciate you greatly
um so please check out the podcast on
there too so I love that but today's
poll is ye Kanye West
he's lost it or
he knows exactly what he's doing oh I
didn't do that grammatically correct but
you know what I'm talking about
I don't know which one it is right now
65 people say he's lost it and Janine
thank you so much for the super chat you
can also support the show that way by
sending a super chat you know you can
send a tip whatever you want you know I
I appreciate whatever little support you
give it keeps me going keeps me doing
the show even when I don't want to do it
I do it you know what I mean so thanks
for being here with that so that's
today's poll question
answer that poll question uh you know
what you guys think
um let's see
um this week a special presentation uh
not special presentation but if you're
in the Austin area this is a last minute
shows Austin area I'm I'm gonna be there
Wednesday and Thursday I'm actually
gonna be there all weekend because guess
what I'm doing my first directing gig
I'm directing my buddy Matt rife's
second special in Austin the tickets are
already sold out for his special but uh
he might be a special guest on my
Wednesday Thursday shows in Austin he
special guest if you can't get tickets
to that uh he's gonna be running his uh
you know his new hour for his special
and so I'm I'm honored to be directing
I've known him since he was 14 I got to
get him on the podcast again he's been
on before he's completely blown up on
Tick Tock guys like he is like I believe
he's the number one comic on Tick Tock
if you can believe that he's got videos
with 40 million views
like he really just is putting into work
and is paying off for him so I'm really
proud of him he's like a little brother
to me I've known him since he was 14
he's like 27 now that's how long I've
known him uh so it's love for him so I
will be doing my own shows while I'm out
there at Creek in the cave Wednesday and
Thursday uh I don't think they have it
on the website yet but it will be so
look out for those tickets if you're in
Austin and you want to come check me out
which it's gonna be Eric and friends I'm
a Hostess show and I'm gonna grab a
bunch of like local comics and whoever's
in town to jump on the show so come
check me out there guys all right
yeah also I want to thank everybody that
came out to Chicago man this past
weekend Chicago five sold out shows
Griffin we out here doing it the Griffin
community
uh Eric Griffin Gaming Community Roofing
with Griffin Community golden hour
agenda Jen all the people that listen to
me on podcasts that I really want to
come out and watch me do stand up do my
thing I'm out here I'm out here in these
streets so I got some dates coming up in
2023 Greensboro North Carolina I'm
coming there I'm coming to Santa Rosa to
the Boys and Girls Club
um I'm coming to the Louisville Comedy
Club all that's coming out in 2023 so
check out check out my website at
ericgirlfriend.com and and the dates are
there you know so check that out so
anyways yeah so Chicago was super fun
super cold I just man I I'm such a LA
California Kid man
such a California kid
um
I don't
I can't stand a cold you you know you
live in a cold place and then you come
live in L.A it takes you like two weeks
and you think cold is [ __ ] I mean it
just happens you know you come to LA
and then you live and you live in this
and then you're like if it's like 60
degrees in La it's Armageddon all right
I'm ready to build an ark and collect
animals that's how ridiculous the
weather is in other in other places how
we feel about weather here in California
I'm sitting over here in Chicago and the
the people telling me Oh it's gonna be a
beautiful day today it's gonna be 50
degrees oh 50 degrees oh that's gonna be
beautiful oh okay let me let me go get
my shorts and my uh you know my slippers
and let's go uh fire up the barbecue
because hey everybody it's gonna be 50
degrees in Chicago that's why so many
people I know from Chicago leave that
City and come to La 50 degrees is nice
get out of here man makes no damn sense
yeah I don't know how I don't know how
people live in cold places like where
y'all at out here on in the chat where
you guys at anybody else at cold weather
cities I don't know how you do it man
the coldest place I think I've ever done
comedy is Alaska I went to Alaska one
time and it was like below something
anytime it's below
I'm out okay
people you know every time I go to a
cold place people always say the same
thing I go man it's cold y'all and they
go well you should have been here last
week
okay that would be like saying
if last week I was dating a chick
5'3
50 pounds
and this week I'm dating a chick 5'3
325 pounds
and you see her and go damn and I go
well
you should have seen last week
hey
they both big you know what I'm saying
like at a certain point
cold is cold so like
what's the what's the temperature you
know what's the cut off like the cutoff
is like
if it's 50 degrees or if it's below 50
degrees
it's the same thing to me it's
uninhabitable that's how I feel about it
all right
so if you had a cold place more power to
you but it's just crazy to me
you know it's just crazy but I got a lot
of stuff coming out 2023 stuff is being
added all the time so I appreciate
um you guys come on out watch me do
stand up I love doing stand up I love
doing the podcasting I realize again I
should have put my disclaimer which I
haven't done I didn't do already but
this like a lot of people ask sometimes
they listen to this podcast and they go
man I thought this was a comedy podcast
I thought it was a comedian I realized
my outlet for doing my comedy is the
stage so I highly recommend you come
watch me do stand up because I am a
monster on stage I'm just I'm gonna toot
my own horn I'm funny okay so come watch
me do stand up I'm really expressive and
I love doing stand-up it's my first love
if you want to see me be funny with
other people I love interacting that's
the other podcast the golden hour with
Brendan and Chris or Jen to Jen with
Matthew Espinosa we enter have a great
interaction but on this podcast
I just
these are my thoughts I like talking
about things
this helps me come up actually with
material because when you
intellectualize stuff and you think
about things in a certain way I have a
certain thought process like to go
through and I like sharing it like this
on my podcast to get my thoughts out and
then it helps me think about things that
I like I will be able to come up with
jokes and the things to talk about on
stage so that's what this podcast is so
if you're looking for some silliness
there's other podcasts for that you know
this one is you're going to be inside
the mind of who me Eric Griffin
so let's get right to it today I'm not
even going like I'm not even going like
you know
mess around and uh make you guys wait
let's just get to the craziness that is
Mr
um Kanye West
where is it
how come it's not going live
I don't know why it wait let me see some
see this is what happens when you do a
podcast by yourself
there it is Boom there he is
there he is y'all look at that look on
his face
all right everybody
I have held off wanted to talk about
Kanye West because I just felt like he
this is what he wants anyway I've talked
about a little bit one time but like I
just really want to get into it now
because of what's been going on recently
um you know I mean the guy he all over
the place man I mean even if you go back
to when Katrina was going on and he was
like George Bush doesn't like black
people remember that remember that guy
like even then you were kind of like
whoa dude is this the time and place for
what was happening and that's really
what I like what brings my mind to right
now it's like time and place
just because you're making a point about
something doesn't mean that that point
needs to be made at a particular time
you know what I'm saying there is such a
thing as time and place you know like
you could need to have an important
discussion but should it be at say a
public place you know let's say you and
your lady or you're you know you and
your significant other are about to have
a serious argument about something but
your kid is in the room
maybe this is an important argument but
should it be in front of this kid
that's the kind of things I think about
when I think of Kanye West it's like a
parallel to that about the things
because
ever since that
George Bush hates black people he's just
been all over the place you know there's
like a timeline on this website August
man of just everything that
has paved away you know to this guy's I
don't want to say downfall but
I don't know I just I don't know what's
going on with him like part of me is
like is he meant is he lost it is he
something mentally wrong with Kanye West
right or
does he know exactly what he's doing and
which one is scarier you know what I
mean which one's scarier to you I ca
you know what I'm saying like is it
scary that here's a guy with a fortune
that he has got kids and he's just out
here
saying stuff and causing a lot of uproar
of unnecessarily and you know he needs
some help like somebody needs to step in
that's you know pretty sad or
is it sad that no this is all calculated
that he believes all this stuff and or
he thinks he's he's some master
manipulator that is going to turn into
something great I don't know
but I had to step in for me to talk
about it publicly because what I do I do
a podcast like I said earlier I like
talking about stuff I had to step in
about talk talk about this about this
stuff like you listen
I don't know why he said this stuff he
said this anti-sort of anti-Semitic
stuff that he said you know I don't know
why he said all that but he since had
come out and sort of apologized for that
and then you know he likes to talk about
love he's like you know God is love and
love is God and on the Instagram all the
time it's like you know we here for it
love love your brother love like love
love love he does all this on one side
of his face and then on the other side
of his face he said he does and says
things completely like I don't get it so
listen this is what I'm saying so he
already has this tone of like
anti-semitic Behavior right it's given
that feel
and who are we to say how a group feels
about something that's being said
whether you agree with it or not if a
group or for people say whoa that's
offensive to me that's hurting my
feelings I think we have to step up and
be like oh okay because listen I deal
with this as a comic all the time as a
comic you deal with this you know but in
the framework of what comedy is you go
all right um all right we don't mean
harm maybe some Comics too but I'm only
gonna speak for me I talk about
everybody nobody gets I I'm equal
opportunist about this so like you can't
say to me oh you hate this and you hate
D that's why you're doing that no no no
I can just find silliness and funniness
and things I could point out I could
criticize or I can praise about
everybody I think everybody deserves it
my feeling of it is if you know
everybody should be you want to treat
everybody equally then let's do that in
comedy that's what I do personally but I
understand when people are like hey man
that what that joke you said it hurt
this person's feelings or that I get
that as part of the game but just
understand the intent so I think that
with a comic you can understand the
intent is this was for humor maybe it
didn't hit the mark but you could still
understand the intent of it right I
don't know what Kanye West's intent is
um this is uh
this is what I'm thinking about with
this so anyways he's he's he has this
sort of like really like
he says this stuff about the Jews man
like he really goes in you know
nobody likes it you know what I mean
Adidas drops them like all this stuff
happens because of his comments
you know I don't know I don't know what
the purpose of that was does he really
mean that does he believe the things as
he was saying that I'm going after you
know
just the way he said it it was so like
man unnecessarily sort of hateful sort
of like you know it's like why go after
a whole group of people who there aren't
as many Jews in the world anymore as you
think and it's it's actually it's
actually frightening if you know and
these people have already gone through
something so terrible in history recent
history if you think about it
and like there's more Jews in Brooklyn I
believe than there are in Israel like
That's how little in terms of the world
population there are so this vitriol and
hate that goes towards these people
I don't understand
it's more personal to me now a wife is
Jewish her family is Jewish I love these
people they didn't do anything bad to
Kanye West so it's like if you have a
problem with individuals point out to
individuals but to point out as the the
race and religion of individuals
as the reason why
that's the total thing you look at I I
just I don't understand that
you know what I mean like you could just
point out hey this person did this
person did that you know I mean it's
just it's not them anyways
yeah I'm trying to I'm trying not to you
know I'm doing this live so this is like
you know what I mean guys
I'm live but I don't I don't mind I I
don't mind talking off how I talk
so he says all this stuff
and then I don't think he realized the
backlash that was gonna happen
you know you know and then you you see
like on this on this website you know
they go
um
they're going down the timeline you know
JP Morgan I think the JP Morgan thing
was happening anyway the drink Champs
removes the podcast
Balenciaga and Karen pull the plug
um you know
CAA drop some MRC shows completed
documentary Adidas takes a huge loss
apparently they they lost like 250
between 250 and 500 million dollars
to cut ties with him that's the money
that they lost
athletes left donda Sports okay I didn't
even know he had a sports thing like
that you know it's just Gap removing
anything that has to do with him
Skechers removes from his from the
corporate office I mean there's so many
things in the timeline that happened
okay so okay all that happens right
and then the thing that I just don't get
is
why he goes on
this podcast
and like
you know
invokes Hitler
anytime somebody says Hitler man
it should make everybody uncomfortable
you know and then here's the thing
if you are a pacifist like this is what
I'm saying about proving a point like
when you have a point even if you have a
good point on paper even if you have
some the sentiment of what you're saying
is beautiful and powerful and it's all
love right
that that still can be said
and it can still be painful and hurtful
depending on context
for him to say like the Jews should
forgive Hitler even if you believe that
statement
that is
contradictory to
the long lasting victims the the the the
the role the line of victims to how this
is that that person affected so many
people in so many lives
it's not up to him
to ask a group of people to forgive
anyone
even if if you're if you're the Dalai
Lama Mother Teresa monk I'll leave it to
those people
but don't use the Bible talking about
love when in the Bible it says
you know eye for an eye
the Bible there's many instances of
Justice in the Bible you want to talk
about forgiveness
isn't it in the Bible where God wiped
out the whole planet and saved only a
few people with some uh with some
animals on a boat wasn't he like yeah
y'all messing up so uh no forgiveness
here we gonna wipe y'all all out and uh
we're just gonna leave then we'll start
over that's stories in this Bible he's
talking about
so for him to bring that up it's it it
is it's a lack of empathy it's just a
lack of understanding how words have
power and so that's what I'm saying is
like is he crazy or is he
using that as a still a way to jab at
these people
I just
I I don't get it I I really feel for I
feel for the guy because
he's just tarnishing his own legacy of a
great artist right great music and then
all this that's happening right now it's
just it's scary you know it's like the
things he's saying he's going on this
clearly these people are like like you
mean to tell me Kanye West doesn't know
that those guys are a hate group
are you know that they they don't
represent this love and you know
inclusiveness and he like he doesn't
know that
of course he knows that's what I'm
saying where it's like why is he doing
this I don't get why he's doing this why
why is he talking to people like that
saying this kind of stuff
here's my point about it too like when
people say like well he's making a point
uh just like I say just because you
making a point just because you think
you speak in truth it don't excuse you
from being an [ __ ]
if your mother was murdered okay
if your mother was murdered and the
murderer is on trial
or he's up for parole okay
and
you got to go
to this parole hearing every year to
make sure this [ __ ] don't get
onto the streets
you wouldn't want somebody there talking
about hey
forgiveness
you know you should forgive
this person murdering your mother
that might be all fine and good in your
in your life in your world but you can't
take away the pain that I'm feeling and
the justice that I think needs to be
served
on this person
but you might be a person that's like oh
I totally understand the pacifists Love
Thy Neighbor feeling but there's a
practical there's such a thing as
Justice and honor and like I said
sympathy and empathy and he's showing a
lack of that
and I think that it is dangerous and I
think that he really needs to look
within himself and be like why am I
doing this
why you do you got kids
you know and then it's like he's always
talking at the side of his mouth and one
second he's being like Oh anybody that
likes a a half naked woman on the in the
internet is a bad person but then he's
on an article talking he's on that thing
talking about Kim like oh I still see
the uh you know I still want it girl you
know it's like what
I just don't know man
I just don't no
and I hope
that
he finds himself again
I mean I I I do think that there's a
part of him that
you know as you saw that one documentary
of his which is a great documentary but
you can kind of see like
how he's just changed like
you know he's like a artist in the true
sense of the word and
but it doesn't mean that the things he's
doing is right or Noble or just
I think he's hurting people
in the disguise of trying to make a
point in the same way and In fairness I
will say in the same way that people
attack comedians who say like oh you're
saying something messed up
you know but I just think that it's
about intention okay and I'm just I
can't tell his intention
I can't I can't I don't know if his
intention truly is
just to be
you know a mouth content just to like
stir the pot or if his intention truly
is to be this
hateful and
angry towards Jewish people which
I
I don't know
you know what I mean I don't know but it
needs to stop
you know what I mean
it needs to stop and and when you see
comments from people who are like oh
Kanye's got a point like like like you
know you you you you you dissect his
sentences and you go well this part
right here well he has a point you know
everybody deserves forgiveness but it's
like yeah but
um not that guy
Hitler really and then you're going to
put a swastika and the Jewish star
together it's like man that's so that
brings up such
pain and anguish for people
that their families suffered so much
and he's really shown a lack of empathy
and I don't know if he's doing it on
purpose
because
you know or if he just this
[ __ ] need medication
you know because he's going to end up
doing some real damage because you know
he is an influential person just if you
look on his Instagram and just look at
some of the comments man you ever like
scroll through the comments and you'll
be like oh man there's people that
there's people that really they're
really digging this dude like they you
know well he's got a point you know it's
like you got people out on the 405
freeway holding signs Kanye was right
about the Jews I don't know if he like
does he feel that way is that what he is
that what he wanted like is he trying to
what is he trying to do so all my Jewish
brothers and sisters out there I'm with
you
any marginalized group I'm you know I'm
with you you know you will get talked
about at my comedy show though but it
ain't it's no hate
you know what I mean like if we at the
same as I say this at the same time I
say look we that's how you treat
everybody the Same by you know
but
is this treating everybody equally when
it comes to Comedy but this don't seem
equal with what he's doing and I can't
decipher his intentions
you know I can't decide for his
intentions but anyways
all right I see all your comments and if
you'd like to you know get into my
comments uh you know right now in the
chat in the live chat right now is on
fire I see y'all
um
so if you uh have a comment about this
you know let's be respectful and I don't
mind it I'll engage you know what I mean
but like you know make your point you
know it's like but but act like you in
person with me you know what I mean I
think that's something there's a lack of
like there's a lack of social
you know just social etiquette and right
now because of the this like distance on
the internet but you know approach me
like you would approach me in real life
you know just talk hey man can I I have
you know I disagree or I agree or hey
this is my thoughts you know I mean
let's again let's keep it cordial and
above board on the uh on the comments
but you know let's get into it I love it
so that's the poll right now six to
eight percent of you say he lost it in
like 38 of you think that he
uh 37 67 to 32 think that he knows
exactly what he's doing
I don't know which one is worse you know
which one's worse you know what I mean
all right y'all
um
doordash this episode is brought to you
by doordash
be the best Giver you could be in this
holiday season with a door dash pass a
dash pass that's actually a great gift
y'all a dash pass it's the membership
that keeps on giving even after the
holidays are over unlock savings on
their favorite items from thousands of
local restaurants and stores near and
dear to them for Less
doordash you know and it's not just food
man you could get like you go to this
like let's say you went to the market
you bought some stuff but you forgot a
few items doordash will go there maybe
you need something from Kinko's or not
Kinkos but like with those type of
stores where you maybe you need some
paper or some printer ink or that kind
of stuff door Dash has it look if you're
struggling to pick the perfect gift for
friends and family
choose let them choose instead with a
dash pass hit that dash pass y'all for a
limited time our listeners can also
enjoy a gift for themselves with a 50
off up to twenty dollar value and zero
delivery fees when you download the
doordash app and enter code riffin
riffin riffin that's 50 up to twenty
dollar value and zero delivery fees when
you download the doordash app in any app
store and enter code refin don't forget
that's code riffin for 50 off up to
twenty dollar value and zero delivery
fees with door Dash subject to change
terms apply
okay guys
um there's that so let's get to some
other crazy stuff that went on man so
um
what's this Taylor Swift y'all
Taylor Swift
I like this little picture of her so I
put it up with a little with the little
with the fire from her website Taylor
swift.com y'all so Taylor Swift
is obviously one of the biggest artists
in the entire world you know what I mean
and she is coming out with a concert
Ticketmaster
the this you know
Monopoly conglomerate ticket people have
decide you know they put it on sale the
whole thing went bananas people couldn't
get their tickets the prices were
outrageous uh now people are suing and
I don't know what I don't know what's
going on so the thing I wanted to uh uh
you know
what happened and who's to blame a lot
of websites about this right now
and and it like sparked like it says
here in this thing it sparked some
outrage from the Democrats and
Republicans with question whether
Ticketmaster would handle the Smith roll
out appropriately so apparently
apparently
like Ticketmaster so they have the
ticket price so there's a set ticket for
there isn't a set ticket price so
they're apparently Ticketmaster is doing
some kind of system which like uber
surge pricing which I find ridiculous
so it's like oh
there's a high demand for Taylor Swift
tickets well let's raise the price I
mean
how much is she involved in that or any
artist that deals with Ticketmaster I
remember back in the day
Pearl Jam do you guys remember Pearl Jam
Jeremy's Booker
[Music]
um they I remember pro jam they were
like
trying to like have a concert and not
use Ticketmaster or whatever I think it
was Ticketmaster right let me look it up
and um
and then
you know so then they had like I don't
know how they did it but it just didn't
work out so I think they even like
boycotted like the the Grammys
Pearl Jam Ticket Master you know I
remember
oh yes no no they don't yeah I don't
think the story is so old
yeah the tears are so old that that
story is so old that I I don't even know
if I could find but I just remember
oh yeah yeah here we go yeah see your
people are really anti-taking Master now
see Pearl Jams it was in 1994 they had a
fight with the giant with the
Ticketmaster giant see I remember that
because like Ticketmaster has a monopoly
on the tickets so like there's a
question of like like
I know it's a capitalistic system right
but how much money should Ticketmaster
make like what service are they actually
providing so they're organizing all the
tickets and make sure people get their
tickets and their website so they should
make some money off that so but how much
should that be a five percent cost on
the tickets ten percent like should they
be making 30 like I feel like if that
money's not going to Taylor Swift then
what the hell are we doing you know it
reminds me of when we used to buy albums
you know you used to buy an album you
buy like you used to have to go to the
record store you buy like a 17 album
right and then come to find out later
you find out that the artist is getting
10 10 cents of that 17
as a consumer and somebody that supports
that particular artist
I don't like that I I that always bugged
me
to me you know I rather go direct to the
you know direct to Consumer and that's
the internet is provided now so like if
they were only getting 10 cents out of
the 17 where's that money going and what
are they actually providing I remember
when they started allowing you to like
uh burn CDs and you saw like man I can
get
a hundred CDs for
ten dollars
then what are they charging for are they
charging for the music and then if they
charge it for the music you go well then
why isn't the artist getting the music
then you find out about these terrible
deals and it's just the music it just
reminds me of that Ticketmaster reminds
me of that so I like how much does the
artists have say in this like can't
Taylor Swift come out and be like hey
in the stadium I want these tickets to
be this price
these tickets to be this price and
that's it and so Ticketmaster charges
the tax and surcharge that surcharge
goes to them and that's the money that
they make because if the money if
there's if there's surge pricing the
money
and the money's not going to Taylor
Swift I got a problem with that
but I also have a problem if
they tell the artist hey
we're gonna do it like uber and we're
going to search price and you'll get 80
and we get 20 because then I got a
problem with that too because then it's
just like yo
is it just about money is it just about
money is there a part of you that's like
hey let me I'm doing this for my fans
I remember Prince had
he he had like some contraceptive forum
and I believe he made sure the tickets
were at a certain price because he was
on the fight on the on the front lines
with the music business a long time ago
I remember Prince was like
he changed his name right to like the
symbol and everybody was clowning him it
was a whole thing but I saw him on an
old show called it was when BT had a
news program so he was on BT news and he
was talking like yeah I had to get out
of this contract they were they were
telling me I couldn't make music and I
wanted to make music and get it to the
people but the music business it's like
they had this these expectations so he
gave this example and I bought this
album it was called the crystal ball
album it was a double CD and it was like
fifty dollars but it has so much music
on it but it was fifty dollars right and
Prince was like so I sold
the
Crystal Ball album for fifty dollars and
he goes I sold a hundred thousand copies
and he said is that a failure because by
music business music industry standards
a hundred thousand copies of an album
you'd be like Dan that's all you sold
but if you sold a hundred thousand
copies at fifty dollars
and you're keeping all the money
or a majority of it that's five million
dollars that goes just to you as an
artist is that a failure
and that's what the internet has
provided direct to Consumer if you think
about it
that's basically even what podcasting is
when you think about some of the huge
podcasts like bad friends and tigerbelly
and Joe Rogan and your mom's house and
Tim Dylan look at Tim Dylan for instance
Tim Dylan's a great example of this
so Tim Dillon has his fan base he is
direct to consumer his fan base
however many people that is
on patreon where he's making something
like three hundred thousand dollars a
month
for his fans
from his fans directly there's no
Ticketmaster the only Ticketmaster is
patreon so they take their percentage
and they go here we'll we'll facilitate
you getting your fan support right to
you
I mean and you don't need Tim Dylan
doesn't need
say like a television show that would
need 9 million views to be considered a
hit and stay on the air and keep doing
Seasons nah man
just needs however many he has even less
than that you know if you have like look
at some of the subscribers of some you
know net of of your big podcasters you
know they got like 300 400 000
subscribers you know that's not a lot of
people in terms of the grand scheme of
the the United States 400 000 people
there's more people in like
counties in Los Angeles in the
California area Los Angeles area then
then fans of certain podcasts but
they're intact they're right with those
four hundred thousand three hundred
thousand fans and then they can make
millions of dollars because it's a it's
a relationship with them and their fan
base
so cut to what I'm saying about someone
who has
a huge Mass Appeal like Taylor Swift
you're gonna sell out concerts
everywhere you have adoring fans
it's like they want to come see you
like isn't that the point like how much
money needs to be made
I mean is there such a thing as like
keep it simple you have this cue so many
people are going to try to get it it's
gonna sell out so what you have it at a
certain price people are going to come
that money should go like what I'm
saying is why is there a Ticket Master
she already has to rent a venue or you
know whatever the concert promotion team
is they're gonna like they had their cut
you know so it's like it seems like man
the big artists like that need to find a
way to to to be big but in a small
fashion the way we're doing it in uh the
the other way you know what I mean
so
you know I don't know
it's it's just
it's just a way
it's just it made me think about that
you know so I don't know how you guys
feel about it but you know getting these
comments you you know because I'm not
trying to take money out of Taylor
Swift's pocket but I just want to make
sure the money is being allocated to the
people that should get it like
to me she should be getting the Lion's
Share of whatever money is coming
because they're coming to see her but I
understand you're a concert venue all
right so you have
you know what I mean she should get the
door and then they're selling parking
there's food at the venue you know merch
so they're like all right well we get 10
of your merch 10 you know who's getting
the lines here the money how is this
business being run and it seems to me
the Ticketmaster they're taking
advantage in this situation and it needs
to be streamlined I ain't trying to take
money out of nobody's pocket but we want
to make sure the right people are
getting the money and they're not taking
advantage of the fan base so anyways
who knows she might not even care about
her fans like that it could just be all
about the money
could be all about the money all about
the money all right so all right guys
that was my Taylor Swift rant
uh
uh yeah it just made me think about that
so I wanted to talk about it
um all right before we oh man I'm
running out of time oh it's okay let's
talk about this man so they got
um I saw this I saw this new car company
it's like this solar car company man and
it you know they're they're making solar
cars right
so light years zero charge anywhere and
takes you everywhere regardless of the
electrical infrastructure our cars are
built for grid Independence charging
from the Sun so my first question was
like how long does it take oh wow look
at that great website my first thought
was like how long does it take to charge
this car like they don't really say you
know
light year zero
um I don't want to sign up for that it's
built with no other electric car
charging on the go and gaining up to 70
kilometers 70 kilometers of range per
day from the Sun okay so how many how
many miles well whatever we'll just
stick with the metric system so 70
kilometers a day
from the Sun
so you got to have it outside and it's
charging so that means like and how I
wonder how long the like how how if it's
fully charged how far will it go I mean
that don't seem like
viable like I mean that's great
I mean as that technology gets better
right it's gonna be like well we don't
even need electricity like this it feels
to me like that technology needs to be
on every building like I feel like
they'll like remember the original
electric car there was a whole
documentary like what happened to the
electric car and obviously the oil
companies and gas they put the kibosh on
that they were like you ain't coming out
with no electric car and then like you
know cut to the Al Gore era where he
just like he put Green in our
Consciousness and then it was already
there and then it just tipped over the
edge and it was like Prius and Tesla and
all these things are are out hybrids and
and now we're getting to the point where
it's gonna be all electric right but now
we're starting to see that well maybe it
should be all solar maybe it should be
all solar now is the electric companies
putting the kai bash on the solar
technology because to me
I don't understand why
like especially when you go to like when
I go to like Phoenix when I'm in Phoenix
and it's 115 degrees
that place is ridiculous in the same way
Alaska is ridiculous when it comes to
cold
115 degrees it's 100 degrees at midnight
in in Phoenix a certain time of year
like get out of here
I don't understand why there isn't solar
panels on everything
like why is it like that should be the
thing
like I don't know where the solar
technology what the level is and I don't
know if we're putting enough resources
into solar technology because there's so
much money in gas and electric now
what's going on because this company is
like outside the box like yo we're
making a so but the car's three hundred
thousand dollars
like you know what's going on so I was
looking at this website and it had like
the history of the solo car now here's
my problem what I was bringing up the
the old electric cars the original
electric cars that [ __ ] looks dumb
who in the hell want to drive that that
looks stupid
and that's what was wrong with those
electric the first electric cars they
look dumb as hell
so you know
like we're like where's I had a um
wait I I put
I had a wait where is it I had a thing
up with like all the electric car
the history of electric cars I had it up
someplace what happened to it oh man oh
I lost it but anyways what I'm saying is
the first electric car is like stupid
and then you were like well nobody want
to buy that because that looks dumb now
you could get any good looking car and
it's like you don't matter what's under
the hood or how it runs it's because
it's about I'm saying like why it runs
if it's electric and it looks dope
you're gonna be like Oh I like that car
but who the hell want to buy that like
why would you want to drive around with
that nonsense
like that looks ridiculous
you know
like what what are we talking about so I
feel like I feel like that's happening
again I feel like maybe the solo I'm
just putting that question out there or
any scientists out there anybody that
knows about this kind of stuff I know
that solar technology isn't where it
could be because if it takes a full day
of charging just to get 70 kilometers
that means it's not really a viable
thing yet in terms of like you can't
just have that car like you got to have
you have to have a second car and that's
just your Fun solar car that you're
showing off with because you spent three
hundred thousand dollars you know what I
mean
[Music]
um
all right here we go
I could have sworn
the history uh wait I had a I had a site
open called the history of a lecture oh
here we go the brief history
of electric cars here it is right here
you know
so it's like you know 1830 to the
present apparently these are the early
electric vehicles I mean imagine you
have a electric
like that looks crazy like look how far
we've come man like look at that look at
that Ridiculousness talk about no safety
it's just like a uh looks like a missile
on it looks like a big
like red wagon like a missile on top of
a wagon guys for the guys that are
listening you know if you're listening
to the podcast right now I'm just
looking at all these crazy original
electric cars you know they were trying
they tried so hard to make this happen
look how dumb that is like they look the
designs of these electric cars are so
stupid
in there in the beginning and you just
go just make them look like a real car
you know like somebody's like look at
that like what like who who wouldn't
want that somebody's cars are stupid
and then in 2011 the Roadster 2.5 came
out and then they came out with these
little like smart cars remember their
original smart cars but they didn't look
safe
and then it started to get good Nissan
came out with the leaf which still looks
stupid but at least it looked like a car
that you would be like okay I starting
to see like a modern car you know and
then it just cut to you know 2012 the
Tesla S and then that's it now it's just
we are just in an era where
Mercedes BMW Jaguar
um uh you know all the you know like you
know GMC Ford look they got the rivian
now they got like you know what is this
one the um the Lucid you know what I
mean and they got now they're going into
race cars they're going into like you
know what I mean it's like damn the the
history of electric cars is crazy so now
like is the next gonna be solar because
if the solar technology is to the point
where you'll be able to have a car
charged you know real fast with solar
well then that solar technology should
be everywhere right and I think that's
why they I believe this might can my
conspiracy theory is that they're
holding that back because then what like
why would our electric bills be high why
would our heating behind our gas and
will be high why would we you know it
would be like all our we wouldn't have
to ravage the Earth for resources
because we got this huge resource in the
sky AI burning power you know 10 hours a
day
but that would mean I guess we would
have to have a lot of batteries like
Tesla sells that house battery so you'd
probably still have to have generators
with some I mean who knows man who knows
where the technology is going but I feel
like the solar technology should be
moving along faster than it is that's my
theory
right what do you guys think tell me
what you think in the comments all right
and last but not least
this was a crazy story that I saw this
guy man was on a Carnival Cruise Ship
and he fell overboard dude this guy
right here
uh he fell overboard a carnival cruise
ship and he was in the water for 15
hours
what
are you
and then they found him
I mean
they like imagine they had to come back
like you know imagine
yeah imagine you want to ship
you with your girl
you know what I mean
you with your girl you with your guy
whatever you're with I'm saying and then
like
you can't find them
I mean
I would be so scared if Rachel and I
were on a cruise and I couldn't find her
like what what's going on through your
head you know like is she cheating on me
and she found some Steward and she's off
someplace in the kitchen or underneath
the boat with the dancers that would
that's best case scenario right
you just can't find her but at what
point you can't find your girl
and you want a cruise ship and you
haven't found her in like four or five
hours and you like
oh this [ __ ] fell over she fell over
she in the water
what do you do
you know what I mean because it's not
like the ship could be like okay we
gonna do a papa UE and we're gonna turn
around and go get him I mean that's
scary
it's scary to think that you know the
thought that your loved one is gone in
the water
all right now imagine you just chilling
on the boat maybe you had a couple of
drinks you leaning over to the side and
you looking out at the water and you're
like oh man you know you're trying to do
the Titanic you in the front of the boat
doing the Titanic I'm kidding
your ass falling in the water
you fall in the water
and you in the water
the water and the boat
you you the boat just gone
you know what I mean and you in the
water the ocean
what's your first thought
you could get eaten by a shark that's
what I'm thinking I mean I would die
from the anxiety of thinking
I'm about to get eaten by a shark I'm in
this water you know what I mean I'm
trying to tread water and a big ass
shark is gonna come and be like oh look
at this plump
just the other other white meat right
here or I'm like you know butterscotch
dark meat and just pow so you every hour
that goes by you sing it to yourself I'm
just cooking in this this salt water is
seasoning me up for a big ass shark to
come eat me that's just the thought that
goes in my head I just that's all I when
I saw this that's all I can think about
you know and this guy was like he all
talking about you know every every time
people get saved they always talk about
how Brave they were like I was thinking
I had to get away and you know but this
[ __ ] was in the water for 15
hours treading water
you know
and it's like you know and then you know
what you're supposed to do I remember
when you learn how to swim
you know how to like uh you know you
float you know what I mean you have to
like lay on your back and just tread
water just barely move and you can float
up top you know you have to keep airing
you
you know it's like a balloon so you like
float I mean I mean but then the water
is moving and any noise you hear you're
gonna be like and what if the ship come
back and run you over and the big ass
propeller I mean
this is that is so frightening
I think that's like one of the worst
ways that would be like one of the worst
ways to die I mean for me my biggest
fear is just being buried alive I I
don't know what we're worth would you
rather how about how it's like would you
rather be
buried alive
or
be out at sea
until you can't swim anymore and drown
like
oh my God that is terrible you guys you
guys think about that foreign
you guys think about that and let me
know what you think in the comments
because that is just I I I I don't know
what's worse you know what I mean I
don't know what's worse
but anyways y'all
um I think that's uh I think that's it
for the day dude I think that's it for
for Griffin and make sure like I say I
want to thank you for being here we're
from with Griffin
um make sure you subscribe
you know what I mean subscribe
um I'm on Twitch I'm gonna be on Twitch
a little later probably after this and
if you want to support I promise you
we're gonna start doing a weekly patreon
you know 15 to 30 minute episode for the
extra extra patreon content so we can
just really delve into it real world
advice from a grown ass man and all that
stuff you know and if you want to send
me beats for the rap recap make sure you
do that
because I get Beats from my man fishy
fishy beats y'all here's another fishy
beat for the rap
oh
[Music]
we singing with them
sometimes
Kanye West lost his mind
he's out of his mind
on time
electric car
s
[Music]
look up at the stars
bar
tomorrow
[Music]
I was like hey hey
Griffin
[Music]
the best
Sarah
[Music]
all the rest I gotta go
[Music]
all right y'all that's the show shout
out to fishy for that fresh new beat if
you want to send a beat you can send it
to me at Eric griffin.com thanks again
for watching the show and I will see you
next week